[Music]
ah
[Applause]
welcome to the break room the new
rockstars live show we are we're
completely live right now at um
502 p.m pacific 802 pm uh eastern
we are here uh to recap what has already
happened at comic con and mostly to
react live to what is going to be
happening in the next hour for the
marvel studios live action panel taking
place down in san diego
we're very excited to cover it live here
with you we'll have all the breaking
news any trailers that come out any
images that get released crazy casting
announcements yeah i'm excited i'm
excited i'm so excited i'm a little too
nervous
can i click this one i wouldn't click it
well speaking of the demo uh we've got
producer john here with us producing
live
we'll see how this goes we'll see if
things get crazy if the images on the
screen will flicker because giant is
pressing a button right in front of you
right next to him jessica clemens i am
manifesting as much as i can for scarlet
witch i i need a mars scarlet witch
no one ever dies yes uh the sharkly
dressed mr erica wusu
i might have accidentally tricked
everybody into dressing more formally
than i was planning on i gotta i got a
text this morning that was uh hey me and
zach are gonna dress up in suits and i
was like oh okay i'll dress like my
normal great self and zach did not show
up
i feel bad you always feel worse being
the the least well-dressed person at a
party and that is me today i apologize
both uh to my fellow panelists and to
you the viewers um a quick couple shout
outs uh we are going to be going to you
the audience a lot we appreciate you the
chat is blowing up right now
uh we know you're as excited as we are
we're going to try to get to any super
chats we've already got jameel hall uh
thank you for saying i don't believe
this is live believe it jamil
believe it um and thank you to uh
yesterday we had some great super
chatters we can get to david jenkins um
spartan uh a couple other folks uh we'll
try to um address all the super chats
and any other chatters we'll be running
some polls we'll be hearing from you as
as the news breaks uh we're super
excited i think we want to start yeah we
already have some news
no no no what you were talking about
we want to start by recapping uh the
warner brothers live action dc panel oh
yeah that was earlier
marvel news yeah slowly rolling in i'm
hawking twitter right now
and i just want to point out because i
don't think i realized this tool a
couple days ago
the marvel panel is not streaming
anywhere if you're watching us right now
and like oh never mind i don't want to
watch these geeks i want to watch the
real thing tough luck you can't you can
only watch these gigs okay
you can either refresh twitter and be
looking at static images and and words
or you can watch us have fun with the
news so um the warner brothers dc panel
yeah we got um we got some good news
from warner brothers in d.c
also uh is that helen
is that uh what's the actress's name
once i saw helen mirren i was like oh my
god they got helen mirren for a dc
that's a very good for dc yeah that is
insane that's like grabbing uh dame judy
dench
some weird stuff from that trailer we
had a a shot from the snyder verse in
the trailer so canon of
multiple shots we had bat
we also got a trailer a new trailer for
black adam amanda waller is confirmed to
be in that movie now sort of expanding
her role in the dc eu
um
yeah how mad is everybody in the chat
that uh henry cavill didn't show up for
his different videos
and no i mean we were thrilled that
great coverage fun panels for both
shazam fury the gods and black adam all
the stars are there we got new footage
everything but we were all a little
bummed no new announcements
no kind i was i would i don't maybe i
understand being bummed i was just so
ecstatic about the shazam tree maybe
that was so rewarding for me
i love it and i was like oh my god i'm
so excited to see zach olivia again i'm
so excited and the whole family they all
walking and saying shazam at the same
time i think that's the most redeeming
part for me and shazam is that the
entire family's involved yeah and so i'm
glad that the second uh the second one
is just family oh yeah oh yeah yeah also
prominent digimon hansu uh
wraps in there i mean he's in that
trailer a lot i forgot it was not in the
original film that much i love that he's
a big seems to be playing a big role the
hall h panel for marvel is now underway
okay
we're going to be breaking that news
anytime anything comes out any trailers
drop anything like that we'll have it
and i know we actually we might come
back to warner brothers there is a
little bit of marvel news we already got
we got a poster yes
we got a poster release just a few
minutes ago
look at that oh that's her that's her
yes that's exciting two big things in
this poster uh that are kind of news
a yeah prominently featured stature
cassie lange
right there right there with um ant-man
and wasp like it's kind of gonna be a
three-headed uh hero kind of adventure
yeah and then the second big thing our
first look at kang the conqueror in his
conqueror kind of classic comic book
form
lord and savior jonathan major yeah
yeah that does look like jesus in the
toast
a comic-con poster so maybe not like the
full theatrical position it doesn't even
have the title of the film on it
on the bottom right there oh yeah oh
yeah real hard to see
it has a cool aesthetic sorry john i
know you just pulled it off but um
a little bit of a starry night and kind
of literally
right my favorite part is hank pym's not
i think it's so funny that he's just
like it's like this is the three and
it's like well i mean he helped he made
the suit he did he was the og man yeah
um we got a couple great uh super chats
we want to shout out thank you benjamin
andrews nary men saying jess as always
best dressed puts you all to shame that
is factual
even on normal days when some of us
aren't wearing suits she's the best
dressed just on a random tuesday or
thursday i like alex
uh alexander link zach looks like a baby
daddy at child support court
i was gonna i was gonna say the old frat
bro who's coming back on like a football
weekend to hang out at his house but oh
either way
i'll tell you it's a little bit better
we do the if you're wondering what's
happening inside hall h right now
they're running a little sizzle reel for
some previous marvel studios
shows and movies and stanley did the
narration i have no idea
what the story is because that's what
that's what i'm being i love that um
yeah that's interesting yeah um yeah so
they're just they're just now going
underway at 509. yeah they're okay
and again we're going to be here kind of
until the panel ends covering everything
live as it happens now a quick thing
here if you are maybe new to new
rockstars hit like and subscribe we got
the best breakdowns theory videos marvel
star wars dc
all kinds of fandoms two if this is
maybe your first time watching the break
room we are here every weekday 3 p.m
pacific 6 p.m eastern covering the
breaking news of the day some
combination of these folks some other
folks uh we have a lot of fun sometimes
it gets very silly always interactive
with the chat come check us out um i
just wanted to recap or precap
what are some of the things we're
looking for to come out of this panel we
know first and foremost yeah well i mean
we know we're well we know we think
we're going to get black panther wakanda
forever trailer hopefully fingers
crossed we've had nothing about that
film it's coming out in november yeah
yeah they've been doing this though with
the thor promos came kind of late we did
we i mean we got uh we got to look at
multiverse of madness at the end of
spider-man no way home but they've been
shrinking their windows now now the
thing is they don't that we talked about
it briefly on here and i'm so sorry to
kill you we talked about it briefly on
here that even if they never showed the
trailer we'd still go see them all
well along those lines my question again
we feel most confident that's the next
big theatrical release uh from marvel do
we do you think we get like full 90
second two minute trailer do you think
it's more of like a teaser for black
panther yeah black panther we're kind of
forever i think they're going to get the
full trade trailer today yeah they have
to here's the question feige is on stage
with a miss minutes hat on
are we gonna get any loki season two
today well i think maybe that connects
to quantum mania oh maybe like over
there
are still together
so that plays nicely into two of the
things we're looking for here right the
next film after wakanda forever is
ant-man in the wasp quantomania uh
that's coming early next year um and we
know they're already shooting loki
season two we've seen some set photos
kind of some uh illegally taken uh
paparazzi
so that's we don't know when that's
coming out maybe hopefully next year
surely hopefully um so yeah that could
be that could those things could be
connected or yeah he just likes the hat
well his hats mean a lot so it's like
so it's like if he's wearing that hat
for the entire haulage panel today that
means that miss minutes is a big a big
thing right now i mean i don't think
it's just for fun
miss minutes also in addition in
addition to the hat miss minutes also
opened the panel on screen
uh saying let me pull up the quote here
uh
shoot i've lost it saying uh you
survived a looping endless apocalypse
and made it here to the end of time
what is it i always say the grant the
grand master
the what about the grand master i said
the grandmaster you know that when
they're getting when he's going down the
tunnel he's like be prepared to meet yes
and i keep saying the other one and i'm
not going to say the other way
phase 4 is announced ending with wakanda
forever
so phase five
phase five begins with quantum mechanics
no way you know dynasty hang dynasty so
real quick way early speculation what
does that mean about wakanda forever
that's a great question it ends space
we've heard them say time and time again
phase four is all about the
repercussions of end game right and like
characters dealing with endgame i'm i'm
kind of it's sort of a coda to the first
three films um i think maybe that just
means like this last film we'll be
dealing with endgame and then we're
moving on to new threats if it ends with
wakanda forever it's gonna be a big
movie well
it's gonna be a big movie they can
introduce a lot of new characters to
bring into the phase five and maybe that
is what they're doing because if secret
invasion is supposed to mimic what uh
end game not mimic but be like all of
them to come together this would be a
perfect time to like throw a lot of
people like riri into uh wakanda forever
and you mentioned like launching new
characters what if we also see some kind
of story lines that we've already seen
what if there are some multiverse of
madness
repercussions in wakanda what if there
is you know some no way home who knows
what might be impacted there bucky we're
still in falcon and winter soldier bucky
was uh always coming in contact with the
dorm a lot here is a photo that we've
got of the panel this is just sort of
what they did for phase four okay uh
yeah so this is already released content
up to wakanda forever right yeah this is
everything that they've already sort of
put out uh although what kind of forever
is not on this list but i imagine that
yeah it kind of ends with she-hulk so
this is supposed to be all of phase four
yeah essentially this okay obviously
another thing we anticipate getting here
today she-hulk maybe new footage uh
maybe tatyana mazlani on stage we don't
know we're hoping that's something cool
we're excited about that show um other
real quick before we get more breaking
news
other things i mean again stuff we're
anticipating before the end of 2022
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
yes is happening this holiday uh season
and then guardians of the galaxy vol 3
in theory next year we know it's being
shot or already wrapped right um so
maybe we get and i think james gunn
tweeted a photo of a raccoon writing a
tricycle or something like that the
other day it seemed like he was going we
knew um will poulter the actor playing
adam warlock is on his way to comic-con
so we think we might get some of that
stuff here do we want to just take a
peek at the whiteboard yeah we've
already sort of ran yeah our very
unofficial
hastily thrown together whiteboard so
yeah on the right things we feel
somewhat confident we might get some
news on maybe these are all things i
gotta i'm gonna interject we've got two
big pieces of breakfast please
here we go we have a release date for
blades
we also have a sort of release date for
daredevil born again
for disney plus for disney
18 episode series coming spring 2024.
18.00
okay so did they already mention that uh
they're keeping in touch with the
original daredevil that was on netflix
charlie cox in theory right
yeah
coming back 17 episodes
they basically already renewed it
yeah that's that's two episodes in one
or two seasons in one basically that's
incredible
that's not a typo and it's eight
episodes or something like that
episodes wow
and blake now we knew obviously the last
time we saw kevin feige at in hall h two
years ago three years ago
2019 he had mahershali on there you know
saying meet blade cool but we've heard
nothing since then yeah we gotta just
his voice in the end credits for
eternals but no announcements no i don't
think we have a director i don't think
we've heard anything about any of that
we have a writer but we don't have who's
the director um
stacy
she's a ghanaian american woman beauty
she's super she's super dope i've met
her a time or two
and maybe again
all those things are probably decided
behind the scenes we just it hasn't been
announced publicly really cool probably
learn a lot more soon
about that but that's awesome
i've got a phase five photo okay here we
go breaking news
please stand by vamp for me fam um
speaking of blade this is a lot of
very
reactions
why i'm also going to apologize because
i get very excited yeah she always
knocks on my teeth
here's what we've got for phase five
i'll run this through for you guys right
now
we might need to go home full screen
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
february 17 2023 secret invasion spring
2023 new title for that one their title
uh logo treatment guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 may 8th 2023 echo series is
going to be september
excuse me summer 2023 okay loki season
two summer 2020. soon that's very soon
and then we've got the uh the marvels
july 28th it looks like a 2023 blade
november 3rd we've got ironheart coming
fall 2023 uh agatha house of heart
harkness oh no it's got a new title
coven of chaos
[Laughter]
and then we have another announcement
captain america new world order may
3rd it looks like 2024.
now uh officially confirmed with a date
in july 2024 wow
those last two things are whammies right
there okay well i mean we had we'd
recently got news that there was a
writer for the next captain america film
and the director and a director uh we
did not have a release date new and we
did not have a subtitle new world order
that's such a good title that i love the
re the the titles the titles are amazing
i love it um can i say that one more
time and then wow we've been speculating
for a long time julie louise dreyfus all
your work has finally paid off my lady
uh we got a thunderbolts film yeah all
that purple hair dye is going to happen
what um most excited for what is it
what's your two most excited for
halloween season blade i gotta say it
november 3rd oh my gosh yeah that's
right oh wow i didn't even put that
together yeah blade yeah
crew is now out on stage but do we want
to go to the white board and sort of
let's let's yeah let's go to the
whiteboard here well first off wow we've
gotten almost everything i mean yeah we
had a checklist now now okay our wish
list here
uh these are kind of things people have
been speculating about we've been hoping
for and i will say
you know maybe the this panel might end
with a bomb getting dropped
we got blade walking out at the end of
the panel three years ago i still
wouldn't doubt if we get krazynski
uh patrick stewart somebody coming out
at the end of this panel but so far
blade confirmed thunderbolts confirmed
it's still nothing on avengers young
avengers um really and and all this
series and the release dates
you've listed besides thunderbolts and
um
uh blade and
uh one more time was the other uh
captain america right these are all
things that were announced in previous
comic cons we didn't know the exact
order uh but we knew they were coming
yeah um very cool i was like you know
eric is always spec vos is always
speculating about
these releases you know coming out in
the order they release for a reason
right things building to each other
building upon each other what are you
saying
i agree with history history no armor
wars
uh i don't see armor wars on this list
they also they this is iron heart right
iron heart is a different series
it's possible hey you know you only have
so much room for a graphic um
this is this is the phase five lineup
this will be the end of phase five with
the thunderbolts so that means we're
probably getting in i i don't want to
speculate too much but it doesn't seem
like this will be the that much mutants
more so well well who knows you can
always throw in some mutants in there
this is definitely not necessary
it's quantum mania too and we don't have
fantastic four on this on this docket
they don't have a director anymore uh we
don't know where that's going to slide
in i bet it'll be within this time
window uh this timeline isn't the
timeline of which uh it's just when it's
coming out it's not like the timeline
and the actual ncu correct
right yeah
release dates yeah we assume they're
following roughly chronological order
within the films as well um well
my mind immediately goes to previous
phases not not this current phase four
but previous phases have ended with
team-up movies
now does that mean thunderbolts is kind
of the team-up movie for this upcoming
phase you could think we didn't we
didn't get young avengers maybe this
will be the young avengers will be in
that film and it'll be kind of a flip
side and just to recap right
thunderbolts in the comics kind of an
anti-hero squad right there's a lot of
people that rotate in and out of
thunderbolts often run by thaddeus
thunderbolt ross that's where the name
comes from previously played by william
hurt
our best
probably this would be the name of a
team that you know honors him in some
way shape or form we think you know john
walker uh u.s agent uh yeah
probably um maybe maybe yeah the thing
is kind of an anti-hero character yeah
they could take some of the young
avengers
yeah you think kate bishop could maybe
get i think her and elena are going to
be number one
uh vaz pointed out
ghost featured prominently in the marvel
zombies
is that a relatively obscure character
they're looking to do more with in the
future marvel zombies make sense but in
the actual show she lost her powers
right and they kind of cured her okay
so a new she-hulk trailer also just
dropped the final she-hulk trailer do
you want to do you want me to spend some
time queuing that up let's do it uh yes
yeah we'll keep uh we'll keep talking
about the release john's gonna run off
he's pulling double duty he's uh
directing producing starring in uh he's
a real auteur today but i think that
thunderbolts are gonna try to get us to
like them
like like that team up i mean if it
includes elena yeah we already love her
we're sold let's be honest yeah we're on
board right and i mean john walker maybe
that's a tougher one right is yeah i
can't wait to see a
thunderbolts who's on it who are they
fighting what is their what are they
doing there is it like a random alien
invasion are they fighting another team
maybe that for now it's called
thunderbolts but what if it's called
thunderbolt's first young avengers or
yeah thunderbolts versus avengers or
thunderbolts versus somebody else right
it's it's really hard to tell also
because now that like thor is gone and a
lot of other of the original avengers
are kind of just like everywhere doing
their own thing does it look like it's
only going to be bucky and
the new captain america because it uh
it's just like
is it just gonna be two versus the
entire thunderbolt team like that's not
gonna i don't know how it's gonna fly
we've kind of been asking that who the
hell are is on the avengers right now uh
what are they doing we haven't seen them
as a unit in a while um i wanna run
through some super chats real quick
benjamin andrews omg we're all we're all
there with you uh benjamin andrews uh
we're all feeling omg right now uh
roland john del doliente daredevil let's
go yes sir
18 episodes if that's true wild if true
um
that i mean it'll be a slow burn but a
good slow burn you know what i'm saying
i like i think they can really extend
daredevil for 18 episodes um my question
is
it has to be like 30 minutes right it's
not gonna be an hour
hour maybe that's why because netflix
was an hour yeah yeah and and maybe they
are
maybe they're playing with formats a
little bit right maybe they are like
we'll do a little shorter
um yeah the street level stuff of
daredevil let's be honest from a
budgetary perspective a little easier to
pull off than loki stuff than moon night
stuff right you don't need as much cgi
it's a little bit more punching dudes
and hallways and stuff like that so
maybe they can make twice as many
episodes for about the same price and i
love the title born again so many
different nods so you know we have
daredevils you know obviously like a
catholic
raised uh person the daredevil the devil
of hell's kitchen so there's definitely
a nod to christianity there born again
jesus is getting saved
and then also daredevil is coming to
disney plus so it's kind of a nice
little middle finger to netflix being
like hey daredevil's born again on
disney plus second netflix baptized in
the waters of disney plus
born again yeah baptized in the water by
topic uh now i think jessica already
pointed out things we did not see on
that slate
no armor wars
did we see a werewolf by night i did it
no werewolf by night either i don't
think they were moved by night which i
think they're still being secretive
right because technically do we know
it's werewolf by night
i mean we're pretty sure we're pretty
sure
there's
announcements we were kind of half
assuming here new rock stars that would
be a halloween-ish kind of thing coming
out this year i could see it's still
coming out they're just keeping it
they're like oh there's too much stuff
right now and if we need to push we can
push that's right and maybe it's more
along the lines of an im groot that's
animated of course but it's something
not as candid it's more just like hey
here's some bonus stuff we're gonna drop
some mini episodes on disney plus uh not
worth putting into a big slate we don't
know um uh thank you frey girl uh
throwing into super jet super chat uh
i'm already gonna shut up and take my
money she said bless your heart frank
bro uh mark cooper daredevil in she-hulk
i mean almost a lot more likely now
doesn't it bob yeah i agree with spirit
douglas i really wanted blade to be a
series
because i want it forever that i think
that's the problem you want just every
week more i want i want a weekly drop of
blade i want
a weekly drop of blood
now what do we think about the rating on
blade what is it other ratings well we
don't know
what do we do do you think they probably
got a stick if they want to make a
billion dollars they gotta stick with
pg-13 or lower it's got it could be
mature it could be mature uh mature is
higher than people that's a tv that's a
gender rating though if it's gonna be a
theatrical release right do they do
pg-13 are we gonna get oh another thing
we did not see deadpool three not on
that list
not yet nice thinking about possible
r-rated first mcu r-rated films has
there ever been a billion-dollar r-rated
movie
i think i think the all-time
highest r-rated movie john can google
this is the joker movie i believe is the
highest earning r-rated movie of all
time i want to say uh so it is possible
yes
yeah yeah and getting a lot of money
their dc's like yes a billion dollars
did confirm make a billion dollars thank
you john um uh oh okay we got a good a
good super chat thank you theodore
harris asking if the thunderbolts is the
end of phase five in july 2024 there's
still two more open movie dates in 2024
announced previously yes okay that's
interesting you're doing your homework
so like marvel kind of blocks off
release weekend windows right that they
later fill in with the actual movie like
we saw that a lot they've been they kind
of flip movies around sometimes and
whatever but they keep those blocks open
because they're like okay what's gonna
dominate in quarter two and quarter
three whatever and so there's two gaps
left
that's interesting good looking out uh
theodore harris that could be uh
deadpool 3 could slip in there maybe a
fantastic four thanks teddy we love that
teddy h coming through do we want to
watch this yes we're going to watch
i'm sorry i was yelling at people i
forgot i was mic'd back there
okay i think this should work fingers
crossed i've never done this live before
let's give it a shot here we go
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nicki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
[Music]
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil blonsky i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing god i really like this
outfit
[Music]
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
[Music]
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
oh
wow dude they were holding a lot back
for the second trailer yeah wow that's
so fun i mean the whole uh direct
address breaking the fourth wall talking
to the camera which is a big part of the
comics of the she-hulk comics she's kind
of like like a deadpool ass kind of
self-aware character took from she-hulk
yeah
um wow i'm obsessed with
uh
so much of
titania kicking her in the courtroom
yeah like straight up brawling in the
courtroom looks great i'm obsessed with
it it looked like they were also at like
uh not a not a rehab or like an
intervention but like kind of a support
group a support group for maybe people
that are heroes trying to and we will
say uh erik voss or somebody on the new
rockstars channel will be breaking down
that trailer fully because there's a lot
there's a bunch of characters kind of
flying by for just a second that i know
he's gonna tell us who they are uh and
what's going on uh there was so much
information i mean honestly
i could watch six or seven episodes of
just hulk and she hulk on an island
training each other giving each other
[ __ ] cracking jokes just keep bringing
wong into everything yeah
literally everything is changing and i'm
so proud of you i'm so freaked out
we're proud of you yes man so i i don't
want to cut us off from talking about
but there's there is more news right we
got the secret invasion crew on stage
now
um lots of talk about secret division
sort of being a dark thriller which is
exciting we think it might take place
during the blip uh there's been talks
about that not totally sure maybe that's
been confirmed yet um fury with no eye
patch and a beard roadie i don't know if
they're showing footage let's see um and
and they've moved quickly on to quantum
media so
they say quantum media is kicking off
phase five we don't have footage from um
we don't have footage from secret
invasion yeah online but
if we see something we'll show you a
thriller but you guys welcome you're
welcome to go back to she hulk
interesting okay well there's not a lot
of secret invasion though how fitting a
secret invasion show they're keeping
pretty secret uh for most of fans not
letting us know a lot of what's going on
dark thriller yeah we've always kind of
speculated it's kind of like a spy thing
right a lot of scrolls infiltrating
different organizations shield stuff
going on
um and that's still all about all we
know um boy there's a lot we could talk
about that she-hulk trailer i'm glad
that it was daredevil daredevil not um
uh
because i kept assuming i was like oh
it's just going to be lawyers
but this was daredevil
so
i'll just go to the end here because
that's well and how fitting just
yesterday at the animation panel we saw
daredevil's going to be appearing in
spider-man freshman year in
the black the black suit that looked
like the black suit right yeah let's see
if i can go back here well he has the
stick it's him right we're not not being
crazy definitely
oh for sure and there's a reason they
don't show them all the way right yeah
that's the best look that we get right
there look at that look at that that's
pretty fun look at them
also any anybody that's still
complaining about the cgi on their show
i've got no time for you
it looks good here go away it looked
really really good that was great and
honestly if that's the make or break for
you on this show then i don't think you
were ever gonna enjoy it right like
there's so much more the the the humor
looked great in that there's some good
bits in that trailer i think some of the
meta stuff the whole
i'm sorry has it been established
previously
in in his other appearances that emil
blonsky abomination can go back and
forth between human and abomination i
don't think so i thought he was kind of
permanently abomination yeah i wonder if
smart hulk is maybe working with the
dodc to sort of help people go back and
forth you know he's decided to be
permanent smart smart hulk but you know
i don't know maybe maybe there's someone
working also in this trailer we see a
lot of i felt like there were like three
different levels jennifer walters there
was just straight up uh tatiana maslany
normal small human uh blown up strong
she-hulk didn't it feels like there was
somewhere it was like kind of like a
smaller she-hulk maybe that was just the
angle it was kind of like normal size
but she's green
um oh yeah
again maybe that was just the angles of
those particular shots also um
uh no mark ruffalo out of hulk form in
in that trailer
um oh so yeah he could probably go back
and forth too because he was normal uh
bruce banner at the end of the
year yes post-credits scene right he
comes in with the the arm sling yes um
he's just choosing because why wouldn't
you choose to stay in hulk
honestly
fun yoga bits uh john is doing some uh
behind-the-scenes work maybe pulling up
some other apps mike's so hot uh i think
he turned off his bike so um
great i want to go to super chats cause
i think you guys have a lot to say here
because there's so much
uh to go off of yeah
saying wakanda forever seems like a
weird end to phase four
well i i i was putting
the onus on it earlier of it feeling
like those earlier phases that ended in
a big team up maybe this phase was never
going to end in a big team up maybe it's
just like yeah we got to end the phase
at some point and that's that's a big
movie to end it on i mean this is also
the first phase with
theatrical releases and disney plus
shows so everything is different about
this phase it's a lot longer than the
first three phases um it's post blip and
thanos and all those other things also
have you noticed that some people say
thanos and other people say thanos i say
thanos you put a heart a on it yeah but
i think it's just the way that i say ace
yeah
shout out to entertainment earth i guess
they're putting us on screens at the
convention
check out their website they do some
cool stuff with collectibles you can go
find out yeah what they're all about
entertainment earth um and go get some
friends of the channel entertainment
earth also if you happen to be in san
diego or maybe you're going to be at the
con tomorrow something like that swing
by them also just looking around
different halls uh philip molina is
lurking
yeah it might be in cosplay might not we
never know
uh wow um
i want to call out we did some polls
here this is a surprising result to me
of the new announcements what are you
most hyped for
captain america new world order hell
yeah
i'm interested in just knowing where
it's going to go um i'm interested in
knowing where it's going and honestly
it's pretty split i got to say i'm just
surprised that it's that high 27
tied with daredevil born again also 27
percent blade 23
thunderbolts 21
interest i would
are saying you know quantum media
trailer they are showing exclusive
footage just for the folks at comic-con
of quantum media we do not have it if we
did we would show it to you but it does
sound like they uh they showed some
footage of quantum media kang was in the
footage some of the majors on on the
stage saying there will be conquering
very excited for that film
very exciting i want to see how we got a
little image in that poster that we uh
posted earlier the first poster for
quantum mania but i want to see how they
do it is he do you think uh because we
know he's kind of got that classic king
comic look do you think that's mostly
like a gore the god butcher practical
effect like that's
prosthetics and makeup do you think
there's a cgi thing going on
i think they're just always into
floating heads floating head posters
will always be the go-to for marvel and
i i'm okay with it but i think that's
just there's not that many villains in
that i don't know
i think it's a it's a helmet like part
of the camera the blue the blue and the
purple is out right yeah
i thought he had blue skin but then in
the eyes when we were doing all of our
research it was like no no it's part of
his helmet
that's in the comics we'll see how it's
portrayed in the film yeah uh but i'm
i'm excited to see what that first
trailer so a couple more details modoc
confirmed for quantum mania
the same character obviously not in the
comics but you know who knows um yeah
and then uh it sounds like they've just
rolled uh rolled james's gun out so we
were we're primed for the galaxy brace
yourselves we'll be getting guardians
news soon uh we'll break that
comes out do we not we don't know we
don't know who's playing modern the
rumors
um but very cool so now can we assume
maybe modoc is in the quantum realm uh
we know also
wild modoc a pretty substantive marvel
villain they already got kang do they
need another big villain yeah well it
could be one of those situations with uh
i'm trying to think of a good example of
this i was thinking loki in in the
avengers film and then yeah and then
thanos sort of well in the stream there
are there are rumors kang is going to be
his presence is going to be felt in a
lot of future marvel properties it's not
like they're going to defeat him in
quantum mania he's going to go away it
could be it could be seen that like
modoc and other villains are going to
start coming out of the woodworks with
kang so it's like if kang is the long
haul uh all these villains are coming up
like loki was to thanos
um a couple other super chats we were
shout out uh john mcconaughey uh a
famous brother to matthew um has
daredevil been in his costume in the mcu
no there's been no out of the mcu
depending on where you want to put the
daredevil show right is it i guess
yeah have you ever got an official word
that the you know netflix marvel shows
is canon at the time yeah we said no i
thought they mentioned like a part of
like it wouldn't be completely wiped
because
also how could why would you do that
we'd go have this conversation with the
agents of shield stance and figure out
we could throw down the parking lot
after this i'm sure uh sir psycho
sidekick uh friend of the show uh with a
great name asking what do you think the
chances are of doom being in wakanda
forever
i want to say hi
you think i i think very we know we feel
really good about neymar being in there
um we pretty much know he's gonna be in
there but we don't know what side of the
you know he might be kind of a good guy
joining up with the wakandans maybe
going against them um well real quick
a speculation that will instantly be
proven incorrect in a couple of minutes
probably
if doom's in it who do you think's
playing doom oh i i couldn't say what if
that no you have to say you have to say
i know that it won't be howard sterling
yeah it's not gonna be already i think
i think what if it is the like keanu
because they are dude they love to do
fan things that are like everything
sorry to cut you off shout out to the
entertainment earth uh
uh booth where uh our audio is on now so
uh oh thank you entertainment
uh what if it was like keanu and this is
not we're not doing like a young doctor
doom this is like
ages older
he's been around yeah we know we know
keanu is in san diego this weekend he
did a panel yesterday with everybody
with coy from the show a couple new
updates from guardians volume 3. james
gunn does confirm volume three is the
end of the guardians of this era of the
guardians in the mcu we think like you
know we might get a new group of
guardians it seems like these characters
are probably sun setting i wouldn't be
surprised after saying the suicide squad
if some of them don't end up making it
through the film yeah we'll see but then
they're also showing uh some some
footage from guardians at the panel uh
at the at the panel right now wow right
but we know it i believe
i i know the holiday special has wrapped
has volume three is awesome
yeah right they kind of shot those
concurrently obviously we'll be getting
the holiday special at the end of this
year no trailer for that yet maybe we
get some footage as as part of this
panel and then next year in the middle
of phase five we get guardians three
right i believe so yeah let me see if i
can go back real quick while you pull
that up uh somebody threw up in the chat
um do we get a punisher in the
thunderbolts move
it i want it i want it so bad maybe you
wanted to play the punisher the john
barrett yeah i mean why would i want to
change
he's great
he was great in that show interesting
they've they've shown a weariness about
that character lately but it feels like
that would be the right time maybe to
bring him in he's getting big on
tick-tock
based on bumper stickers i sometimes see
around town he's he's always been big um
oh someone said michael fassbender is
doom and i i think that would be a
really fun
but he's been magneto for so long that
is also true i don't think they're gonna
do a ton of crossing over of those x-men
someone said nicki
doom minaj in a happier life yes let him
live let him live my mom sent me a photo
of him uh on his honeymoon asleep on the
boat and i was like he's finally at
peace
he's finally yeah with the pepper pots
you can rest now we did run a poll we
did run a poll thank you shout out to
off-screen producer dodson who's
managing our polls today
uh what's a bigger announcement
daredevil in she-hulk or modoc and
ant-man pretty split
54 of you said daredevil and she-hulk uh
i agree i think probably just because we
all love daredevil and yeah that's had a
show but that was like i haven't seen
the modoc show myself oh i was like
saying that's a close pole though
yeah pretty split um and then a poll we
ran a long time ago we didn't we didn't
get to uh who are you more excited to
see in quantum mania running away with
it kang 87 percent over stature no love
for casually
back to guardians volume 3 some
information from the footage that they
just showed uh we did get a look at
gamora we don't know where she was she's
hanging out with the ravagers now so
that's a really interesting turn for her
i wonder so
this gamora's
thanos is dead so she doesn't have a
father she doesn't have she's a little
aimless she's probably
but she knows everything because that uh
nebula like file filled her in
everything i think it is just more of a
i don't this isn't no this isn't my man
i don't know you guys that well i've
never fallen in love with star lord i've
never hung out with these guardians
characters yeah i'm gonna go this way
some uh some additional info we did get
they did get a look at adam warlock uh
again oh again uh will poulter and then
my most excited uh aspect is uh herbert
windham the high evolutionary we sort of
we sort of guessed he would be in this
movie but it sounds like it's confirmed
and so we might uh rock it uh of course
the high evolutionary played a big part
in rocket in the comics and rockets kind
of creation uh also rockets uh lady love
interest laila lila i think lila it's
kind of a the the uh otter equivalent to
rockets uh raccoon um maybe we see her
great tidbit uh maria beccalova who was
in uh the borax sequel yeah is playing
cosmo the space dog if you guys are
familiar with the guardians of the
galaxy mission breakout ride at
disneyland there's a little cosmo
yes yes yes so i don't know if it's a
full cgi character or what the story is
but it sounds like that's the character
a wonderful actress that's very cool um
cool wow and we'll probably be getting a
little bit more
uh guardians news yeah i mean i i assume
they're going to be wrapping up the
guardian stuff soon because we haven't
gotten anything from what i imagine
they'll end the panel with which is
black panther wakanda forever
i gotta do this every time
we're hoping we're gonna get a trailer
for that all trailers that are getting
released well first off um uh content
coming out on the new rockstars channel
uh our very own eric vos is going to be
doing a recap of everything yes a much
more succinct sort of uh put together
version 10-minute version
and then he's going to be doing a
breakdown of this wakanda forever
trailer we hope we're getting
momentarily that'll be coming out on our
channel monday some of these other
trailers we might be seeing a she-hulk
trailer sometime later this week
um maybe breaking down some of this
other footage that we're seeing but yeah
whatever's coming out uh your friends
and new rock stars are going to be
digging deeper absolutely i've got a
little log line for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 2.
it's james gunn's describing the story
as how rocket is one of the saddest
beings in the universe oh god so i think
it'll truly be like a very cute sad like
you know he's got his trip on his
shoulder like trying to figure out
why he is the way that he is i'm going
to cry during this maybe i wonder if a
lot of the plot is going to be around
the high evolutionary kind of rockets
creation kind of wouldn't be surprising
yeah 100 yeah they've always teased it
like where he came from his his uh holes
and markings on his back one time he was
taking his shirt off or whatever yeah i
think we got uh fully everyone else's
kind of story except for maybe mantis a
little bit but yeah we are missing his
so this is the closer yeah and the
question is the first movie gave us like
drax's kind of arc right you get to get
over his grief the second movie
especially star-lord got like his arc
with his father and his kind of
franchise we saw nebula
i mean groot can only say three words i
don't know how much of it i agree
with you discovering a lot of him so uh
yeah yeah that'd be great and man like
the both the cgi bradley cooper's
performance
the way that character like the the
dialogue uh that's very exciting that
that movie is gonna maybe center his
story about this oh my god kermit in the
chat i think it says kermit i don't have
my glasses rocket 100 gonna die then
i think there's a good chance a lot of
them don't make it yeah why why why not
it might be drax i could see drax being
the one that dies because he would do
anything and just being like yeah
yeah
especially sacrificing himself for one
of his uh fellow guardians he's been
saying this is the end of this saga of
this for these guardians makes me think
that like you know he's probably pretty
precious about these characters
if he can kill them off so that they
don't get you know misused or mishandled
i don't think that that would happen but
you could selfishly speak you can always
have future guardians movies because in
the comics a lot of other characters
have cycled through the guardians um
even this version that we've kind of
come to know with star-lord and gamora
and friends is a later version of the
guardians of the galaxy right there a
bunch of earlier uh folks in there um
there is some some of the guardians cast
is on stage chris pratt is there no uh
karen gillan is there she says nebula
will have a little bit more levity in
this in this
gone she can movie of not have you know
someone looming over her shoulder the
whole time she's lighting up a little
bit love it line up a little bit she's
finally gonna eat that fruit
bear trap 124 uh in the super chat
saying something we were talking about
earlier pat and oswald do my section
bring them back it would be so fun even
if they don't now again the rumor is the
actor corey stoll is going to be playing
modoc that's an interesting choice
because he literally played a different
villain in the first film and we thought
he died um but you know what i i
wouldn't put it past marvel if they
don't let them be the voice of modoc
they throw him a bone and he gets a
little cameo in that film well he i mean
he does play pip in uh in the eternal's
post-credits team
full cgi characters are
true
that's true that's a great point thank
you john yeah uh we all forgot that he's
pimp
i bet he might have forgotten about that
he's like oh i'm doing another modoc
recording this weird
he was on the boys for like 30 seconds
yeah not the mcu jessica
without crossing streams i always cross
streams
oh this is a good one um john dunham
saying in the super chat what if the
reason he wants body parts is because
rocket wants to be human
right that's kind of a recurring theme
he's always like trying to trade people
for their
you know bionic arms or whatever do they
want to put like a little raccoon head
on a human body
[Music]
it is interesting i mean if you wanted
to get a little dark there could be a
little like cycle of abuse somebody that
kind of formed him out of disparate
parts and now he's kind of perpetuating
that of like gathering body parts to
form some kind of thing um a little
frankenstein metaphor going on with him
in the high evolutionary uh he didn't
want the winter soldiers wakandan arms
yes yeah that was that i was trying to
think whose arm was he asking for yeah
i'll say this too in case people out
there are sort of you know we we had
mixed reactions to the thor love and
thunder film and people you know this is
sort of also another jokey type movie in
the mcu a lot of people in the audience
are saying like that was an insanely
emotional trailer people are getting a
little missed yet and now the entire
cast is sort of like choked up on stage
so it does sound like this movie is
going to be a lot heavier for guardians
32 movies you got guardians
someone in the chat said why are you
guys wearing the suits you guys have you
ever watched like espn when they're
draft joined election night coverage you
know we take comic con seriously this is
our coverage three of the four of us
didn't seriously i showed up uh yeah i'm
not starting this and you definitely
won't finish it i know i feel terrible
and again a quick plug for this show in
general this is maybe your first time
watching the break room we make this
show every weekday 3 p.m pacific we
cover whatever trailers are dropping new
episodes releasing news casting all that
kind of stuff every weekday here live
from new rock stars we also get
extremely silly speaking of silly monday
our very next break room show is going
to be tamicon 2022 named after
uh tommy bechdold our sometimes co-host
who's currently officiating a wedding um
it's hard to say what tomicon's gonna be
beyond
strange yeah chaotic even chaotic i
think he's a great descriptor you
definitely want to tune in this monday
to witness comic-con
uh live okay i can't stress enough we're
live right now that show will be live uh
against probably our better judgment
um uh
oh uh
corey westerhold saying
twitter's saying bill murray is playing
modok
i believe did we there was a rumor going
around bill murray is going to be in
quantum mania
um interesting twitter seems to think
he's playing modoc as of yet that's
unconfirmed interesting thank you corey
westerhold for reporting that um
interesting uh it sounds like bill
murray is not playing modoc but he is in
the film yes bill murray uh i have a
tweet here that says bill murray's alien
character knows janet so it sounds like
a different character
playing an alien not motive somebody
from the quantum realm somebody from
that uh uh
uh that little city we saw in the
background that we speculated about
endlessly since man and the wasp yeah
um and yeah and big clark is saying in
the super chat what about fantastic four
no fantastic four anything we thought we
would maybe get casting we thought maybe
we'd get a director that would make
sense well
no it doesn't make sense because i was
about to say if they do end with
something big in um
uh in wakanda forever that they'd bring
it into the next phase that is the
fantastic four but maybe they're i don't
know you guys i i you heard my beef
about the mutant stuff i think they're
kind of trying to like
push that and fantastic four a little
bit they're like give it a second it
should be said to you know this is not
the end of marvel announcements we're
getting yeah d23 in september that's
right where you know who knows what
they're going to talk about
a lot of trailers should be fantastic
for we could see trailers
yes um
interesting one i just want to point out
we've been talking on the channel a lot
all the breadcrumbs marvel has dropped
recently in these post-credits scenes
not so far not reflected in the upcoming
slate uh no new doctor strange film
right with clea
charlize theron that character um no
eternals film uh aries and uh pip as we
previously mentioned
both sequel movie and series have been
announced but not on that slate i guess
the one in the one of the eternal's post
credit scene we did see blade talking to
um kid harrington's uh black knight
character now does that mean black
knight gonna show up in the blade film
possibly oh i think yeah could we get
some other maybe midnight sons
characters i hope i hope i really hope i
want midnight signs i want ghost rider
to show up again come on i think the uh
i think that movie is like what's gonna
be really fun for me any dark horror
kind of stuff i'm really into so that
showing up in the mcu is what i'm really
actually waiting for do any of you think
they'll
throw morbius into the mcu
because he didn't talk to vulture at the
end of morning
it sounds like chuckwoody iwuji is in
who's playing the high evolutionary is
fully in costume right now
um if you're just joining us now after
this we'll have a full sort of rundown
of all of the news that you might have
missed from the panel eric voss will be
uh breaking down everything in succinct
tight detail and we'll have all cool
photos from the event that we can dig up
online um some people are saying
guardians of the galaxy footage leaked
we're not going to show it but if you
find it good for you yes um love that
that actor john just did a good job
pronouncing his name i won't attempt it
uh great in the peacemaker series uh
that's the same actor right uh james
gunn if you ever book a gig with james
gunn he will continue to hire you for
the rest of your career okay he's a
loyal man
very cool oh a couple other polls we've
been running in the chat thank you for
everybody who's participating in that
thank you uh off-screen producer dodson
uh has san diego comic-con 2022
delivered so far
73 saying yes
i want to hear from that 27 saying no
yeah man thank you jess w for saying hi
yeah you're right like i thought we were
maybe going to get she hulk and black
panther and then go home but this is
great i'm waiting for wakanda forever
yeah yeah that's what the 26
yeah the no will go way up if we don't
get a one kind of forever trailer for
sure i want uh
do you think uh this will be the last
guardians of the galaxy was another chat
and yes uh apparently
i think we ran that poll before james
gunn confirmed it on on screen
um uh ice boom bon doc thrown in the
chat javier bardem daniel craig for dr
doom or magneto
um
yeah i guess you're not saying they
split the role right yeah i know greg
would be very funny
when i say funny i just imagine him
talking to kang and it'd just be like
jonathan majors and daniel craig in the
same room talking to each other
interesting parent yeah
uh that's great okay a quick recap of
everything yeah let me pull up the uh
the slate again here we go
uh
it's so pretty i know right okay so we
got a ton of news for ant-man and the
wasp quantomania we know that modoc is
going to be in the film uh that's coming
february 17th 2023. we got some tone
confirmation for secret invasion right
that's going to be that tone guys well
yeah you know that's important some of
these questions have been a little
lighter you know and so hearing that
she-hulk's going to be a half-hour
comedy um you know hearing secret
innovation is going to be just like a
maybe for grown-ups yeah
i mean marvel grown-ups four marvel
zombies marvel zombies we got word
yesterday is gonna be a tvma so so who
knows where they'll go with some of
these shows okoye is going to stab
someone with that spear
she she's so hot right now did you watch
the little bit of panel about uh the
walking dead all right i gotta interrupt
no you're gonna attach it before
november 8th 2024
november 8th 2024 so it's a couple years
away wow but they also have a phase five
sort of photo up that i think they're
going to be filling in the blanks for so
wait or you're saying no facebook we
were just saying yes
so fantastic wait we are currently in
phase four they are dropping dates for
phase six this is they they have
this is what you call generational
weapons fantastic boys they already have
the phase six already lined up
i think they knew there'd be a revolt in
san diego if they didn't give us some
fantastic four news i can't wait to see
this wow
wow they're ending strong uh no no as
far as we know no they're not ending
they're not ending come on we gotta get
black panther
but uh note now that's just a date yeah
right john and that is so far out
they're not even close to shooting that
so no casting news no direction well
they're still yeah they're still looking
for directions we might get more info
here is here's the photo they've got a
bunch of dates out there november 8 2024
who knows what else that is and that's
the graphic that's been going around
right that particular depiction of it
you've shown that logo before i'm gonna
be 80 by then i might
i know let's hope we're all still here
uh wow yeah if a meteor is about to hit
earth the first thing i'm going to say
is i'm never going to see this
avengers king dynasty and avengers
secret wars
2025 and i'm so sorry i am so sorry i
said you were ridiculous for thinking
that i'm ridiculous i'm ready
you're saying this is an infinity war
end game type of situation back-to-back
avengers i don't know that's just what
it sounds like that's what those two
avengers movies are gonna two avengers
movies ending a phase makes me think
that you know the brothers are working
on uh on uh secret wars they were
bringing it up they were like we kind of
you're saying the russos are coming back
today
bookend the multiverse saga of of the
mcu four five and six being the kang
dynasty
some kang will survive to end phase six
ah good for jonathan majors that guy's
gonna be gainfully employed for the
foreseeable she's gonna keep their
muscles up yeah and now they're gonna
close with wakanda forever so that's the
phase six news
we're getting we're getting what kind of
forever people are coming out on stage
this news makes me feel pretty confident
we know almost everything is five yeah
we've got everything in facebook they've
at least given us the beginning and end
of phase six now no
no word about a mutant anywhere right we
just got we just got miss marvel
confirmed first mutant
they announced fantastic four
in secret wars
yes two more avengers movies coming uh
wow
that's big um
and and we don't know again we don't
know the rest of phase six maybe then
maybe all the rest of phase six is
nothing but wolverine solo movies
we don't know i would also say like you
know it's very possible that they put in
new movies into some of these thoughts
or theories or whatever they've done
before inhumans never ended up happening
you know sometimes they move things
around how did hall h san diego comic
con become our church how did he become
our religion i literally am sweating
like a like a cinema in a church
i'm going off at this news secret war
there is the final sort of graphic for
phase six here oh my god they're going
to reach secret wars by 2025 25 20. now
i do think they might they might need to
work on their graphic design because no
i think that's intentional do you think
they think they're keeping them generic
kind of no no because the first avengers
one over there king dynasty is like
filled in and that second one secret
wars is hollow for some reason
i think that's intentional something's
going on i like it i like where your
mind they're all dead or wearing like an
another like maybe emptied out hollow
like a purgatory type dimension for that
last avenger you know what this is also
telling me it's also telling me with
secret wars it's like if someone dies
this phase next phase they might show up
again in secret wars get a different
different point so don't cry don't cry
because they're dead they're gonna watch
your show scarlet witch show up in that
john i'm sorry the dates fantastic four
what's the date on that fantastic four
i've got november 8th i believe 2024
yeah and then secret wars what is the
may 2nd 2025
i'm sorry secret wars is november 7th
2025. but that's that's a year
yeah short fit they're getting a whole
phase in a year the current phase we're
in yeah as a whole yeah well that's
starting in 2019 right
yeah now the pandemic might have grouped
some stuff but still it's been a three
year
run yeah
what if kang is going to become the what
we see dr doom in secret wars kang is
going to be that version of
big bad
i think that's why they set it up for
afterwards it's gonna be something big
and they're all gonna be transported to
a different planet and they're all gonna
have to fight and then kang's gonna be
the leader of the bad team and as
somebody pointed out in the chat which
secret awards do we want to see as we
know like marvel has done super wars a
couple times different versions they've
all been pretty cool uh one was kind of
a little cheesier 80 or 80s one but uh i
love that one that one's the most fun
galactus falling from the sky so he'll
go and said bro i'm literally gonna be
in college when secret wars goes out
uh yeah the the bifocals on the break
room cast will be thick by that time so
so people who are wondering what's
happening with the wakanda forever panel
they did a little bit of a musical
performance it sounds like and then uh
ryan coogler is now taking the stage so
maybe we'll see a trailer musical
performance
who performed did it say don't don't
know
come out with drums
left that uh he loved that set to come
to this one yeah
he had this term off of the rolling loud
stage
someone said russo's have to do two
movies right for secret rewards you
gotta think they're definitely they're
gonna do it
slap in the face if they don't i'm gonna
slap them in the face and on top of that
yeah i do think after talking it out on
the break room i do think it's gonna be
like three movies i don't think like
yeah dude i don't think
they just announced i mean
they're gonna move so much that's
already probably five and a half hours
worth of film um they're gonna move a
lot of things around and i think they're
gonna make it into three movies i think
they could do a similar thing they did
with avengers and game and infinity war
which is just like the movies preceding
it
are sort of like mini avengers films you
got a lot of team ups and it sort of
leads you to uh
yeah i love doesn't it feel like with
that with phase six being so tight and
again they're all years in advance we
don't know if that's gonna stay the way
it is right now but that it is gonna be
like like the infinity gauntlet saga
they're gonna plan out all the films in
that is that again a lot of the films
we've had lately have been kind of
origin stories and kind of separate
stories maybe kind of finishing some
story lines starting new story lines but
that is going to be like a seven or
eight film tight actually less because
it's only a year right it's gonna be
like a six four five six film tight
story line yeah and we have disney plush
shows so that could fill in a lot of
stuff in between movies and four movies
sorry i didn't i'm so sorry i'm just so
i'm sorry yeah taking it back what are
they going to cover at g23
what are they even going to do
we get trailers for some of these things
that are we're just now getting
announced that is true
again things that we were kind of
waiting on that we haven't gotten again
no word werewolf by night it is uh
i guess they can't talk about it if
there's not a full moon
no footage for the marvels no footage
from loki season two no footage from
ekko even though we know that is
shooting or is already wrapped uh
as well as shooting iron heart has been
shooting anthony ramos told us shits
fire
no word on armor wars in general even
though hasn't don cheadle talked about
that in the past that that is happening
oh it's been announced they threw it up
on a screen at some point yeah so we
don't know if that's been canceled or
rearranged or whatever no footage from
agatha house of harkness um
and as of now no guardians footage right
they showed guardians footage at the at
the convention but nothing no publicly
released oh my god
and no no quantomania trailer now the
way marvel's been doing it lately you
don't get a trailer until the previous
movie has kind of come out basically
right so probably not until after we're
kind of forever in november maybe then
we get our first look around then we get
our first look at quantum mania yeah you
know we'll see i think i i wouldn't be
surprised we have to get new footage for
something at d23 right that's
interesting we gotta get started and it
can't just be where we'll find it
they're giving us
yeah d23 is everything right so they'll
announce star wars news
yeah
to again the warner brothers dc panel
we started talking about and then we got
interrupted by a lot of news though to
be fair there were two great trailers in
that panel and nothing else what did dc
if you wanted to talk more about you you
got to give us more more
okay we need more news
not just news of infighting we need
content disney warner brothers discovery
we want to see what your phases look
like please water brother's discovery
so they are they the the what kind of
forever panel or the what kind of
forever group is still on stage ryan
coogler is giving just a nice tribute to
chadwick boseman saying
uh he was here five years ago debuting
footage for for black panther and
sitting next to him was was t'challa the
late great chadwick boseman it gets a
big applause and then he says the impact
that he made on the industry will be
felt forever we put our love for
chadwick into this film but we also put
our passion um so it does feel like a
lot of this film or maybe even just the
beginning or whatever will be sort of
honoring him and and you know even the
character and all that kind of thing i
don't know that i'll be able to make it
through this credits without me
maybe an inflatable
what will the um uh themed uh popcorn
tin look like for wakanda forever this
was the third eleven thousand
it'll be like how at the dodgers games
you could get a dodgers kind of helmet
baseball hat full of like popcorn or
whatever it's going to be black panther
helmets
it better be a full panther
a couple of super chats doctor doom may
be a variant of kang from sky night 84.
interesting theory but that feels like i
think i pitched that for a rogue theory
and i was i'm very into it so go off sky
night i i like it i i just hope that
doesn't mean that they kind of use up
two great villains in one you know what
i mean as long as they both get to have
their own kind of unique story lines oh
they would be two different characters
yeah just a good point same thing you
know they threw the uh planet hulk
storyline into ragnarok so that wouldn't
be the first time i mean yeah i think it
would be just like how they did loki
it'd be loki and uh still
yeah um now i also wondered that phase
six does that mean maybe
phase six is the kang phase even though
we know he's already shown up in phase
four and he's gonna be a presence in
phase five because like kang also has a
huge history with the fantastic four is
he maybe the villain there and
throughout that phase leading up to the
kang dynasty wow
hard to know what i do know is that
neymar is now confirmed for black
panther
we get watery of a condo yeah we sort of
knew that was going to happen we had the
line in end game with the koi saying uh
underwater earthquakes yeah or whatever
we deal
time to pay the piper
uh
wow um cool and then that that actor
tina huerta am i pronouncing that am i
making that up uh i think what did you
call me
oh god with that tie on you
once we started talking about what kind
of reason i get very aggressive
and then actors playing nomura atuma uh
aneca anika riri williams sounds like
she's going to be in black panther
wakanda forever and neymar are all uh
and what's the duke is there too oh
that's right
couple couple super chats i want to
shout out thank you to everybody
chatting in general super chatting we
appreciate you uh you've thrown us a
couple uh doubloons there in the chat
helps us bring this show to you uh
sartan i'm sorry if i'm mispronouncing
your name could secret wars end up being
a full-on mutant in movies and x-men
movies in phase seven like maybe that's
how you introduce mutants in secret wars
and that leads into the following things
you're gonna wait that long
uh 2025 truly that we will have cleansed
our palate from all the fox newton
movies by that point but i want the
mutants in secret wars yeah that's the
hard part well but i think maybe that's
kind of what he's proposing right like a
lot of his secret wars story lines are
like together of all the superheroes
make him fight on a planet right that
could be well you could gather up a
whole group of superheroes we've never
seen before and that's one way we meet
them right right joe speaking of mutants
also says deadpool nowhere to be seen uh
deadpool 3. maybe that will be announced
at d23 maybe
yeah i don't know they do have things to
announce at t20 yes right even though
this does feel like everything ryan
reynolds is you know has been beating
the deadpool drum that guy wants to make
more deadpool movies for sure
um we saw that there was a great photo
of him leaving kevin feige's office a
few years ago maybe it was just to
exchange uh holiday cards we don't know
but we assumed it was talking deadpool
i'm really excited
yeah
i know right
williams will be fine especially because
now that they opened the world to
wakanda and like is open to everybody
else it's like oh where is this gonna
take stem and i can't wait to see like
henry williams be like i have access to
so much more now
and see where it goes yeah in the united
states because he set up that uh that uh
wakandan like or science center in the
bay
right yeah i'm sure by now it's like
everywhere i'm assuming by now it's like
there's one station everywhere and maybe
sherry's like overseeing a lot of it
yeah
oh but i can't wait my nerves
the fact that they acknowledged it i was
like that's not going to happen forever
and then i said boom here it is
i know it's funny the russo brothers
going out and saying like no you haven't
talked to anyone about it but uh
here we are what i like about that later
like a lot of other celebrities do
they're like they have such a hard time
trying to be like no the rooster
brothers were like we're waiting for
them to ask us that's a good way to
negotiate russo brothers big weekend for
them
if he was like uh yeah we're using
someone else so that's why you haven't
had any talks with us yeah uh rooster
brothers latest film the gray man
starting uh starring chris evans and
ryan gosling out on netflix right now
it's a fun watch um uh real quick we had
we loved it at the time but we had to
kind of rush over because there's so
much news the change of the title of for
the agatha house of harkness agatha
and she's still like trapped within
wanda's magic and she's they're like no
you're agatha don't you remember and
it's like
i would also love that i mean we got we
got word that a what-if episode
yesterday during the animation panel
it's gonna be set in the marvel 1602
universe which is kind of this elseworld
universe of like you know victoria uh
elizabethan england uh marvel characters
what if the
agatha show is set i mean we saw her in
like um you know colonial
uh america all the way to kind of
present day what if it's set in some in
between time what if i said like 1822 or
something like that in salem mass you
know like that's where that coming is
yes they have referred to it as a com a
dark comedy so it'll be an interesting
you know where they toe that line i
don't know but do you uh they already
are singing in the chat do you think
that it was agatha all along will be the
intros
nick morris in the chat saying i think
they shouldn't tell us when deadpool
comes out make it a surprise like it
just shows up in theaters like we don't
[Laughter]
thank you for your generosity uh dylan
bodie in the chat we appreciate you jane
knight uh uh miss marvel hassan actually
astrolabe and the sentient star is in
his ring okay i don't understand those
words
we might need eric voss to decrypt that
for us um but i assume it's a good point
thank you
um picking the chats we uh we got a big
number wow yeah we want to shout out
everybody who's been watching the break
room all week long uh we set a a stretch
goal for the week to hit 1500
and that would unlock comic-con for
monday we did that a few days ago
this is that we have two thousand
dollars
yeah we're gonna have a full cosplay for
monday we're gonna have to do full
cosplay tomorrow for tomicon again tune
in tomorrow uh sorry monday apologies
monday uh comic-con it's the second
biggest event on the calendar after san
diego comic-con
um it's gonna be wild d23 bigger than
d23 bigger than uh warner's fan dome but
you know i just thought about that is
that maybe why warner brothers didn't
give us as many they're still doing that
this year well i don't know i don't know
that it's been announced but maybe
they're saving some of their stuff for
fandom
because we didn't get any joker news we
know there's a joker project one of the
songs yeah i wanted a musical from lady
gaga
lady gaga we wanted gaga on stage um uh
so yeah maybe there's more shoes to drop
there we hope for dc
uh but yeah tomicon coming monday it's
going to be wild tune in
3 p.m pacific this one uh
um real quick we'll go through the panel
here as john waits i think we're
patiently waiting for a wakanda forever
trailer as soon as it if if you want to
know what's happening it's it's they
have a lot of the actors out on stage
and they're just sort of talking briefly
about you know the movie and how excited
they are
uh it's uh i don't have a ton of great
info for you guys but as soon as there's
good news big news uh we'll be talking
about and it feels like they're taking
their time with this one because it's
the next film yeah it's kind of kicking
off the press tour for wakanda forever
again they've been radio silent on it
they've given us nothing up until now so
it's going to be a big reveal but real
quick let's go down the panel not
counting what kind of forever because we
haven't gotten a
trailer or any kind of big news on that
what's been your favorite thing
so far you know my secret wars
the secret awards
is huge i i just we heard the title king
dynasty yesterday or the day before what
the copyright is i don't know if it was
real
uh kang dynasty that i hope it's better
than the age of ultron the k the dynasty
of kang i hope it's a little bit more uh
you know impressive than that but that
has to i love the i love the word the
choice of words dynasty yeah dynasty
he's the king the duck dynasty
is it doug dynasty if it's doug dynasty
i'm going to sign me up i'm still going
to see him get a cameo in there
what about you zack favorite part oh man
it is tough there was such like a wall
of information and excitement you know
what i got to say when i look at the
slate maybe it's because some of these
2025 things are so far off i'm just like
i can't even process that yet
i'm really jazzed for blade and we're
getting blades soon
sooner than i expected next year next
halloween that's awesome i'm very jazzed
for that yeah i wish it was a little bit
sooner yeah only because november 3rd is
when i start putting on my christmas
decorations oh so you don't have to do
it right after the movie yeah um it's
like bloody christmas decorations we do
have some quotes rolling in uh from some
of the actors dominic thorne who's
playing uh rio williams or ironheart
says the impact of black that black
panther had on the world was massive and
so to be a part of it returning to the
screen and to play this beautiful new
young mind speaking of young adventures
we didn't we forgot to listen we were
books
um and to be a part of this perspective
is a blessing and a gift i think like
everyone everyone working on this movie
it sounds like they had like a really
wonderful sort of emotional experience
and really had a great familial bond
between all these people
yeah yeah that's one of those movies you
probably get like tattooed on your right
yeah
yeah
who's playing namor says i come from the
hood seriously and thanks to inclusion
i'm here who says this uh uh
huerta oh so it's confirmed yeah yeah uh
confirmed yes uh thanks to inclusion i'm
here he says a lot of kids out there uh
their hoods are looking at them on stage
dreaming and they can make it he says by
the way namor is amazing
i'm so excited okay i hope he would
yeah
thirsty thespians and no no slander here
every marvel actor is going to root for
their own character to appear in a
million marvel properties because they
all want to get paid who wouldn't and
they know there's a multiverse so if
they die
they could come back in another universe
yeah
who would imagine haley atwell would
still be getting marvel checks in the
year of our lord 2022. good for her
yes and beyond yeah i was super excited
for blade but i'm gonna say wakanda
forever especially now that we know it's
ending phase four yeah so that is gonna
be super huge i will be right back we
have a trailer for black panther
mcconnell forever
right back john's gonna be uploading we
gotta get ready we're gonna watch it
live as part of this uh and then we'll
react to it afterwards uh john's gonna
be pulling that up asap we're all very
excited to see this
i can't wait
yes wow i can't wait i can't wait i
can't wait can't wait real quick this is
your last chance to do it before we see
the trailer what are you expecting to
see in it i feel like we're going to get
a little piece there has to be like a
big person like not a big person but
like someone right someone somebody this
is the last one this is the last one i'm
not even an introduction really what if
captain marvel just shows up out of
nowhere um oh my god well she's stuck in
carmela's
the speculation of like okay we know
neymar is going to be in there are we
going to see a marvel character that is
not a probably going to be in yeah
is there another non-wakandan marvel
character that we might see in this yeah
hurry up
john's jen's fingers are bleeding
and scrolling so fast
i love it i also do you think this
trailer is going to position neymar as
the antagonist as the bad guy as the
character fighting the wakandans i think
so
i think it might be a
a situation where he's for most of the
movie that's who the wakandans are
fighting against the atlanteans but by
the end of it they come together to
fight another different antagonistic
force
yeah that's great uh and and that
antagonistic force might be
hey might be doom we'll see great great
comic story arc uh um
featuring neymar and dr doom at
different points working together
against the wakandans uh really good in
the last 10 years um okay yeah we're
very jazzed again we're going to be
watching live here for the first time
the wakanda forever trailer then
reacting to it afterwards we appreciate
everybody that's been here today uh
marvel just squeezed all the juice out
of this lemon uh they've kept us here
longer than we anticipated we thank you
for staying here with us thank you
everybody who's been in the chat filling
out polls sending us super chats uh we
feel the love when we send it back to
you we hope everybody's having a good
saturday afternoon evening we are so
your tap of your fingers your tap
tapping your knee out we can't be
chomping at the bit for this it's like
we're waiting for the envelope to open
the year you know i'm about to take a
chunk out of this table
i'm i'm worried about jessica's
well-being right now she's sweating just
like the secret wars reaction you almost
your head almost popped off i can't call
the number on my bracelet i help me i
fall in and i can't get up
i need this
woman a life alert
call 911. i'm so excited the secret war
is one i'm just
i i i it's more so me being taken aback
because i was so stubborn about it yeah
okay
i need a couple seconds but yeah okay
we're ready to roll we also real quick
before we roll this we want to thank uh
betterhelp helped us just bring
our our show to us uh this week actually
if you check the description of this
video and click on that link you can get
a great discount on better help we
appreciate them sponsoring the show and
we appreciate you folks for uh choosing
to uh uh patronize them and help us out
as well all right okay here we go
unmuted
let's give it a shot
[Music]
don't shed nothing
no woman no cry
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
soldiers
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
have i not given everything
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
whoo
i gotta go watch that seven more times
what a different flavor also what a song
what a everything
it was yeah
oh
everyone here is the littlest i'm
needless right
heavy emotional and then like oh also
insane action set pieces also all these
people we don't know who they are doing
cool stuff that we don't know what
they're doing i mean very little
dialogue
like just anything just angela basically
basket with the cat fiery i can't wait
for that monologue of oh yeah like this
is my place and i'm gonna go
off quick oh my god angela bassett
angela bassett angie auntie angie i'm
glad that they were like she's gonna
step up like she's gonna be because in
the first movie she is still there she's
still a queen but it's like we didn't
she didn't have as much power and and it
was coming through and this they were
like we're going to give angela bassett
her own seat she is going to get her own
somebody pointing out in the chat is
that final shot when we see somebody in
what looks like a black panther suit and
the claw's coming out it kind of looks
like the killmonger suit
it's
it's
golden black versus the like purple and
black we don't know we don't know who
that is that could have been shuri that
could have been we don't know it should
be said to uh we will have eric vossel
do a reaction of this i'm sure he's
going through frame by frame as we speak
right now that'll be out on the channel
uh the first thing after this video
wraps is going to be out on the channel
i'm actually we're going to wrap this up
and i'm going to help edit that yes and
then uh on monday we'll have a full
breakdown of this trailer uh for you
guys can i go out on a limb this is dumb
because it's like recently biased
jessica's wrecked she'll never be the
same uh is that like maybe the best
marvel trailer we've seen in a long time
i loved it incredible it was an homage
and it was a trailer like it was like it
was setting up things for future but it
was also like
you guys as the audience we see you we
hear you and we're and we're also good
and get hyped and like
please give us your money like i mean
the tickets are the tickets were already
sold but the tickets are double sold now
right like
anything you need to see like such a
craftsman he he is such an incredible
director everything he's done has been
so full of like heart and life and this
movie i mean from the first shot and we
were all sitting here we're like oh my
god is that a funeral you know what is
it um and a water birth it was an end
and a beginning in this trail and in
like it was all white like kind of like
a wedding right like we don't know what
was going on maybe even a a coronation
or a crowning of a new leader or
something like that yeah those uh that
scene of the um them jumping over the
wall and then the people from the water
climbing up the wall i was like
i'm gonna go off in this movie yeah
people people are asking is the if the
panel is over this this was the last
thing for the panel so we're going to
stay here with yeah we'll just have a
couple more minutes of recapping
everything we saw and continue to react
that kind of forever you know and then
we've all got to go
sleep re-watch that uh sleep for the day
we go watch that trailer 17 more times i
mean wow
what a trailer uh very excited and and
again we don't have to wait no 2025 2026
uh razzmatazz for that we're getting
that movie in a matter of months
the crowd went crazy they played the
trailer a second time and then
in a very oprah moment kevin feige gave
everyone a miss minutes hat to go
you get a hat
jessica's shell shocked oh my goodness
uh again enough for me on this show i'm
done now
video coming out on the channel soon
reacting to every all of the marvel news
and then we'll get a breakdown of that
excellent what kind of forever trailer
on the channel
monday
as soon as we can we're going to pour a
ton of effort and love into that yeah
very excited to watch that breakdown
yeah should we one one last time before
we go just sort of look at the upcoming
slate for the next few years of our of
our collective lives yes yes all right
let's see here we go
from the top don't be all right baby
it's going to be all right thank you
all right
stephanie horton in the chat saying it
was almost like being at san diego
comic-con watching with us thank you
so uh apart from black panther wakanda
forever which we just saw trailer of
incredible stuff we've got ant-man and
quantum mania secret innovation
guardians volume three echo loki season
2 the marvels blade iron heart agath the
coven of chaos daredevil born again this
was a crazy day not to mention we barely
talked about captain america new world
order and then the thunderbolts and then
of course fantastic four avengers king
dynasty avengers secret wars what an
amazing day mark your calendars for the
next five years
really truly wow
also you know what i uh not only do we
not get most of what the phase six is we
just got kind of the book ends
there's a lot of disney plus stuff yeah
not on there yet
right uh in the holes yeah that they're
going to be filling in so it's like
a lot of connective tissue there on the
disney plus channel uh yeah yeah no
mention of a hawkeye season two which
has sort of been rumored like that yeah
so you know stay tuned we'll probably do
another one of these special live events
during d23 um thank you guys so much for
sitting here and watching with us uh
again uh eric's gonna have a reaction to
this black panther kind of forever
trailer out on the channel next then a
full recap of everything it's gonna be
like a 45 minute video who knows of
everything that was announced today and
then on monday we'll have our black
panther wakanda forever trailer
breakdown yeah work on that starts today
subscribe to new rockstars if you're not
already subscribed subscribe for all of
uh these and other great marvel related
content and watch the break room every
weekday 3 p.m pacific uh our faces other
great faces and voices talking marvel
and all kinds of stuff we appreciate you
thank you yeah thank you jess eric zach
john we'll be back on monday with
comic-con with brandon barrick and tommy
bechdel if you missed them today they're
off doing more important oh no we're no
no no no
we're going to be all right
bye guys have a great rest of your
weekend we'll see you guys